(groans)
- (groans & laughs) He's crying!
He's crying! (laughs)
- That's not funny, Nick.
(dramatic music)
- I'm not feeling good right now.
I'm not looking forward to this.
- This will be a first.
(tweezers click)
- I'm a little concerned. I
think it's gonna hurt a lot.
- Trying to find the
thickest one I can find.
- The thickest one?
- Right.
- This is really weird.
(laughter)
(breathes heavily)
- Oh fuck, that's a big hair.
That was in my nose. What the fuck?
(groans)
- Ready?
- Not really.
(groans)
(yells)
(laughs)
- Can I hold your hand?
- [Brunette] Ready? Yeah.
Yeah.
- Let's do it.
- [Brunette] Ready? Go.
- (yells) Fuck, ow.
Oh, that's so gross.
- [Brunette] That is really gross.
- It's really long too.
(yells)
(groans)
- [Blonde] Go. (groans)
- (yells) I didn't even get you!
- No you--
(groans & laughter)
- No.
- [Blue shirt] Yay!
- Whew, I'm tearing up.
- Let's not do that anymore.
- Can we do it again?
- No, not really, no.
- [Grey shirt] Oh.
- Yeah, it's not enjoyable.
It's like if you want to
make yourself cry, do it,
but, no.
- That's the worst thing ever.
I don't know why people would
do that at all. (laughs)
- I'm sorry, I'm sorry I
plucked you. That really is.
- You look so much prettier.
- Yeah?
- Yeah, absolutely.
- The girls are gonna like it?
- (laughs) Yeah!
- Awesome.